who am I I am a white supremacist
Trumper who uh likes to spread
conspiracy theories
they're going to put that in a bunch of
Articles now they're going to say he's a
self-admitted blah blah yeah so now I'm
uh I I consider myself to Wade to the
left of the democratic party I'm to the
left of Bernie Sanders um to the left of
AOC in the squad and for that you get
called a right winger and you get called
a white supremacist and you get called
all kinds of smear words because you're
exposing the establishment you're
exposing the game that there really is
only one party we have a unit party
because as Ralph Nader said 20 years ago
the only difference between Democrat and
Republican is how fast their knee hits
the ground when a donor enters the room
wow and so that's what this is the world
we're living in right the stuff that we
were supposed to be afraid of Donald
Trump doing Joe Biden is doing in the
corporate media gets America to cheer it
on because they don't know they're the
most propagandized people in the entire
world